massé ja d'appareils smartphones
appareils photo tu prends l'appareil et
puis tu fais ton film même si le profit
et la seule chose qui compte aujourd'hui
donc le marketing appli pouvoir sur
l'artistique et le putsch personne n'en
a parlé
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui tout le monde m'a dit tu
n'as aurait aucune chance de faire mais
les poulains aujourd'hui c'est fini
c'est trop décalé
[Musique]
il faut faire des comédies quotidienne
réaliste contemporaine et qui coûte rien
toutes les chaînes de vente ça tout le
monde heureux c'était déjà pas très
facile de faire des films avec une
petite tendance fantastique ou science
fiction comme un porc en france mais là
maintenant ces données calandre
impossible le profit et la seule chose
qui compte aujourd'hui donc le marketing
api pouvoir sur l'artistique et le
putsch personne n'en a parlé
et c'est dans tous les domaines jean
paul gaultier me disais qu'il ya des
gens sortis d'écoles de commerce qu'il
explique comment faire des costumes par
contre moi ce qui me rend optimiste et
que les outils sont de plus en plus
accessible c'est à dire que maintenant
avec un appareil photo je vois tout
autour de moi alors le faire un film
avec une qualité qui comme eux c'est
incroyable
[Musique]
faut qu'ils commencent par des courts
métrages menace que c'est le seul
endroit où il y aura pas quelqu'un qui
va dire ce qu'il faut faire
donc maintenant on a des outils et on a
déjà vous a parlé smartphone un appareil
photo je prends l'appareil et puis tu
fais ton film mais je voulais faire ça
va faire il ya que ça qui compte à marcq
oubliez pas qu on a eu la chance
incroyable de faire six longs métrages
enfin deux ensemble et avec une totale
liberté ce convoi peut faire aujourd'hui
c'était pas des courts métrages des noms
aussi on a eu cette chance on aura tous
les rails mais en tout cas dans le court
métrage c'est ce soir et nous voilà
c'est un moment et puis surtout vas-y
fais je prends un téléphone un ordi
aujourd'hui tu peux donc pas ce que ça
c'est un truc que tu avais trouvé que
c'était vachement bien ces êtres ou
faire parce que les gamins des cas
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire pour être
metteur en scène et moi je leur dis
toujours mais tu veux être tu veux faire
tu vas être mettre en scène nous te veux
faire des films pour ça c'est une bonne
question un de vous faire
[Musique]